[Music]
welcome to planet scale making planets
kilju spatial processing possible with
bigquery GIS this morning we've got a
really exciting show we have two types
of geospatial modeling and food supply
and it's before lunch so these are gonna
be kind of the grains and the foods and
the proteins I guess so on the first on
the top top path across the top it's
gonna be Duke art labs I'm one of the
cofounders of decart labs and how we
leverage our take our labs platform for
machine learning for modeling various
grain productions across the United
States and then we need to ship those
grains around the world and so how would
you start to model and understand
shipping and supply chain logistics and
those types of challenges then David's
gonna come up and he'll be focusing more
on the protein side of things and and
fishing David's from global fishing
watch and he's going to talk about how
they leverage earth engine to observe
and track vessels for illegal fishing so
where these things these two workflows
come together is on a common vector set
vector data set excuse me
and that's called a is if you're not
familiar with a is that's an automatic
identification system for how ships send
their location to avoid collisions and
both decart labs and global fishing
watch are both using bigquery as a place
to put these massive amounts of AIS data
into bigquery and that of course is
Google server lists you know managed
data warehouse and so no matter how many
billions and billions of rows of AIS
data either of us get we're not worried
about bigquery being able to scale up or
to be able to run our queries to provide
type of analysis then finally for a
really exciting finale
we have Moshe and Moshe is the big queer
the chief bigquery officer so I don't
know how you get the chief bigquery
officer title but what's really cool is
he's gonna show us behind the scenes how
Google built these geospatial functions
so that's really gonna be exciting so
it's been announced that bigquery
geospatial is launching today in for
general availability this is the only
cloud data warehouse that has
first-class support for geo at GIS
functions and GIS data types so that
means that GIS functions are now backed
by the full force of the bigquery team
and bigquery service level agreements so
that helps me at decart Labs write
service level agreements and make sure
my customers and I can get support and
serve my customers and so you might say
well what's new since the beta if those
of you that have been in the beta I'll
let you read through all of these
features but I'll tell you about the the
two that we're leveraging at anti-car
labs we're we've really seen big
important improvements from the ability
of the speed of joins and how fast joins
are running in we do a lot of that so
that's been a big difference and then st
geo from text that's really useful for
us for ingesting large polygons so those
are two that that are useful for us I'm
sure everyone has different workflows
decart labs if you're not familiar with
us we were founded in 2014 and we're
kind of this anomaly in the startup
world I guess we're not in the Bay Area
we do have an office here in in New York
but we're up in the mountains of Santa
Fe New Mexico where I can get us quick
ski lap in before for heading to the
office in the morning and we've been
around for you know a little over four
years and the reason we're up in the
mountains is because myself and the rest
of the founding team were scientists and
research
and engineers at a Los Alamos National
Laboratory and there we focused on you
know our expertise wearing their hoops
areas such as sorry I'll go back machine
learning remote sensing and kind of
understanding how changes impact the
planet so we we leveraged massive
amounts of satellite data to build those
types of models to see you know what
insights might impact our customers
their supply chain all of their
logistics and how can we help them
become more efficient we leverage a wide
range of GCP infrastructure to build our
multi-tenant machine learning SAS
platform and we originally built all of
this for our own team and how to make
our team as effective and productive as
possible to be able to really rapidly
iterate on machine learning models and
train them get results tweak the models
retest revalidate and how can we do that
in hyper efficiency and we since
externalize that to our to a lot of
different customers who have ideas
besides just what we've done and one of
the benefits of GCP is you know these
are all micro services based and there's
all types of persistent data stores that
I can Mitch mix and match each micro
service to just pick the right
persistence layer for that and just like
with micro services you might want to
with remote sensing we also have to
select the right use case for the right
data set and be able to fuse those all
together to come up with insights that
actually matter so one of the
fundamental challenges is is being able
to combine these these data sets for the
problem it's not usually just one data
set gives us the straight answer and I
think you're going to see that from both
of us
today and so when I say satellites you
most people will think and with
satellites tracking ships
I would guess a lot of you might think
this beautiful picture of a ship on the
ocean
look at this in red green blue kind of
build the left column or the left part
of this diagram but often there's a
problem with this there's a pesky thing
called clouds and I'm not talking about
cloud computing
it's clouds getting in between the the
satellite and the and the earth and so
those can abstract our view so sometimes
it works and sometimes we get really
good insights from that but sometimes we
have to look at other types of sensors
so if we move to the middle of this
diagram we see another type of sensor
called synthetic aperture radar and an
example of this is from the European
Space Agency you have a satellite called
Sentinel 2 and what our central one
excuse me what this does is it sends a
radar signal the satellite itself sends
a radar signal off the earth it bounces
off the earth and then the satellite
receives that signal on another orbit
this is great because it penetrates
right through clouds so that's problem
solved except the refresh rates aren't
always really helpful when you're
tracking global supply chains like seem
like shipping and so that brings us to
this third data set and that's a is and
so these ships are are sending a a
message or a ping to a ground station
and the satellites are being able to see
and locate where those radio frequencies
were transmitted from so lots of
pictures in this this talk I hope you're
all ready and that's fine with everyone
it's it's GIS so it's very visual crowd
here on the left we would have the types
of the different bands of light that we
would use for modeling agricultural
crops so you can see there's the bright
green and purple is showing you know
basically photosynthesis and where it's
occurring and in the crop health so
we're able to build models that that
kind of predict the yield when we move
over right one and we see that synthetic
aperture radar what you're actually
seeing the differentiation there is the
fields that have been recently plowed
and slightly disturbed
that's the types of things we can see
with Sentinel 1 then you have a clay
minerals ratio and then finally on the
far right we have a high-resolution
human visible red green and blue
spectrums of light so that's things we
would use for a more kind of computer
vision or tensorflow type models that
would be things like maybe detecting oil
pads in this this case so when we work
all over the world we build crop models
all over the world for all different
types of crops in this talk I can only
kind of go into a little bit of detail
about one and I'll talk about corn and
you see it you might say well what's
this a machine learning model of well I
think the only thing this could detect
is the state of Iowa and maybe the City
of Des Moines but it probably isn't
useful for classifying much else really
on in this example but we have a lot of
really complicated processing steps to
get get to that point we have to be able
to identify and segment out all the
different fields we have to know what's
like an urban area because we don't want
to include those geographic areas into
our models then we finally have to run a
classifier to say is this a cornfield a
wheat field a soybean field those types
of things and so then after we had those
types of information then we can finally
start to estimate how much food is being
produced in every single one of those
fields and roll that up into various you
know the state level a county level and
national level to be able to model the
overall food supply and and how that
this year's crop production is going to
to come on to the market and then we'll
back test this for you know 10 or 15
years and seeing every single farm
everywhere in the US every day and then
saying how did that model do in that
that drought year or in that that year
we had flooding in Iowa
and in test the model at de 200 how did
it do so that's and then we'll
constantly iterate on that to try and
make those models as accurate as we can
so that gives us an idea how much food
is being produced at what parts of the
country but one of the next things is
often that's not where it's getting
delivered to it's going to somewhere
else in the world so problems we have to
think about are you know what about rail
capacity how do you get from the field
or the elevator to the river where you
would have barges and those barges would
take these commodities down down the
river then there's traffic and traffic
delays on on places like the Mississippi
River believe it or not how busy are
they is is there delays at the port is
weather gonna impact those routes are
they lays in places like the Panama
Canal can i reroute and get you know a
more efficient speed up or better fuel
efficiency those types of things so
here's on the bottom we're showing
optical so that's the you know human
visible red green blue beautiful
pictures that we talked about and on the
top we see the AIS route and that works
even with cloud cloud cover so a is
let's dive a little bit more into that
what is its automatic identification
system so this is is the message that
ships are sending out to avoid
collisions it's sending you know their
unique ID where their position where the
course is and they send kind of it's a
ping message and given intervals to to
tell each other and in track so they
don't all collide and this data set like
almost any type of sensor data we're
seeing this just explode dramatically a
single AIS vendor from from just to cart
labs just one vendor we use captures
tens of billions of AIS pings a day and
so what's happening is we're having this
explosion in
base and as satellites go from these
research devices built by NASA that cost
a half billion dollars to things that
grad departments are building for a few
thousand dollars and they're getting
cheaper to put into space that global
coverage is getting quicker and quicker
so you're just seeing this infinite
growth so that's we're having a no ops I
don't have to add discs or capacity or
processing cores to be able to ingest
that data starts to become really
valuable so here's a global
visualization just to show you the
traffic patterns and about 90 percent of
global trade is actually done over over
the oceans so as you recall we are
showing corn yields in Iowa we're like
you know the next thing is being able to
model and predict you know how how
delays or impacts on those barges going
down the waterways in the US where those
those delays are happening and and how
things are progressing it's it's not
that different than you know if there
was a delay getting off the Bay Bridge
on your way here this morning but this
is for shipping and over the past few
months or over just a few months we've
queried I think this was a query over
four months on the Mississippi River we
saw this is showing we were able to
query down and see that there was a
little over 350 thousand thousand ping
messages for ships on a like larger
scale okay what's happening when they
get down to the bottom of the
Mississippi so this is looking at ships
that were in New Orleans and also in the
Panama Canal and where were they going
and so this is what used to be an
incredibly hard query to actually
actually execute and it would be really
hard if we were doing this in and things
in other types of databases
as it's just an incredibly long-running
query so finally then what happens when
we start to get into the Panama Canal so
in this scene we're showing synthetic
aperture radar and you're able to see
the ship starting to line up outside of
the Panama Canal and that's sending that
radar signal down and you'll be able to
see the difference in the purple and
green they see the ships out there and
how that were a signal reflects off the
water and but again remember the problem
here is we're only getting passing over
the spot in the earth every few days so
it's not very high temporal cadence so
we need something better so again that's
where we go back to things like being
able to put this data into AIS and be
able to query in this a is datasets into
a queryable form and then we can start
to see the Panama Canal and much closer
to real-time with many many data points
and you can see ships waiting on both
the Atlantic and the Pacific side to the
left is colored in dark is wherever
ships have have really slowed down you
can see kind of to congestion zones in
the Panama Canal and then the green
we're seeing where ships are moving at a
much much quicker rate so these are the
types of models and insights we're
trying to build for our customers to you
know really enable them to make better
decisions on their shipping and supply
chain and logistics and and and impact
their business and so that's great for
grain and grain modeling but the next
we're going to turn it over to David and
he's gonna top them about fishing thank
you Tim
hi my name is David charisma and I am
the director of research and innovation
at global fishing watch and I'm going to
share with you a similar workflow where
we take radar imagery from Cemil on
across the globe process it using Google
Earth engine to identify where we think
there are vessels all over the globe and
then combine that with a AIS data using
spatial bigquery to identify where we
think all the world's fishing vessels
that are not broadcast in a location are
so I work for global fishing watch
global fishing watch we're an
independent nonprofit dedicated to
improving transparency in the industrial
fishing industry we originally founded
in 2014 by Google and to nonprofits sky
truth and Google although now we are our
own nonprofit and we are entirely
Foundation supported we have about 30
staff globally distributed although we
do beat up every now and then and we
have almost 40 thousand registered map
users that go to our website global
fishing watch org which you can visit
and look at our interactive map of
fishing activity so our goal is to
increase transparency in the world's
fishing industry and when most of you
when most of us think of fishing this is
what we think of however this is not the
fishing we are trying to attract a
global fishing watch we are trying to
crack fishing that looks much more like
this so this is a picture from China at
the end of their summer because at a
port where fishing vessels are leaving
to fish and the way China manages its
fisheries is that during the summer
there's a three month large actually now
a four month moratorium or no fishing is
allowed and at the end of that all these
mussels are allowed to go out and fish
so if you're a fish this is what's
coming out for you you can zoom out and
just see the scale of this fleet and
China does have the world's largest
fleet but this is not just China you
know we are fishing all the world's
oceans using large industrial vessels to
catch fish and of course wheat this fish
but that's how we're we're fishing the
oceans and what we've done a global
fishing watch is zoomed out one more
time using all of that position data
from AIS
to map all of the fishing activity by
large industrial vessels that have a is
a is system as Tim mentioned is a system
by which vessels broadcast to locations
so that other vessels can see where they
are and it's only required on large
vessels so again we're only seeing the
large ones here but we can track what
their activity is so you may ask so why
does this matter I mean it looks
exciting but why do we care about
transparency and fisheries here's why
over a billion people in the world
depend on fish for their primary source
of protein yet one in third fisheries
are overfished globally and about one in
five fish are caught through means that
are illegal unreported or unregulated so
in summary fish is critical to the
global food supply especially some of
the poorer people on the planet yet it
has a high ecological cost we're not
doing it sustainably and we're
monitoring it extremely poorly and it's
also involved in a lot there's also a
lot of crime and the legal activity
associated with it so our belief is that
if we can track fishing activity more
more efficiently make it more
transparent we can make it make it both
more sustainable and also provide food
for people how do we do it so our key
technology is we we use two machine
learning algorithms - - neural nets to
identify fishing activity and if you
look at these are showing the tracks of
a trawler which is a type of vessel that
drags nets behind it a long liner which
dry wood sets long lines of hooks and a
percenter which in circles circles fish
with a net and these are the tracks from
the AIS data where we just plot how they
move and you can see with your eye how
differently each of these vessels move
so we're able to train a classifier that
guesses based solely on how the boat is
moving what type of vessel it is we also
can tell what our non fishing vessel is
so we identify what are the tug boats
what are the what are the tankers what
are the passenger vessels so that we can
ignore those and just look at the
fishing vessels we then have a second
model which is based on how these boats
move what is the what is the likelihood
that it's fishing we put those two
together
to a map and we're able to make a global
map official activity by these vessels
and here it is for one year of activity
and this is a this is probably the
biggest I've ever projected this this
map although I've looked at this many
many times I love this map it's
beautiful to look at it's exciting you
see all types of I see new things every
time I look at it but it's not just a
pretty map creating this global data set
of fishing activity has had real impacts
in addition to being the first-ever
global map of fishing activity the data
has been used to help identify six
places for marine protected areas which
has an area the size of Egypt we've
gotten a few countries including
Indonesia Peru and Panama with Indonesia
and Peru being two of the top five
fishing countries in the world to commit
to transparency in the last three years
our data set and our research partners
have produced over twenty peer-reviewed
papers and one of these papers
identified how looking at how boats fish
identified how subsidies are helping
drive overfishing and so we've now that
has led to an engagement over the World
Trade Organization where our data is
being used in negotiations to identify
how we can change twenty billion dollars
in fishery subsidies a lot of which
drive and promote overfishing
so this is really exciting it's really
great what we've been able to do but
there's one problem which is that not
all the boats broadcast the location and
also some of them don't
broadcast the right location so so far
we have tracked the positions of all
vessels voluntary the broadcasts and
their positions
what about vessels that tamper with
their AAS device or broadcast wrong
positions so as a reminder the way we're
telling where these boats go is that
there is a GPS device on these vessels
with a radio that then broadcasts the
latitude longitude timestamp and a few
other characteristics to other boats
nearby and then also to satellites some
vessels have changed the latitude
longitude that the bras broadcasting so
it says there's somewhere else we're not
sure why some of them are doing this but
some of them are and the result is you
get wrong positions in the data here's a
great example down there on the bottom
left of this you see a boat says it's in
the southern
if ik then it says he goes self through
Antarctica then goes to negative 95
degrees south which is impossible and
then back up it's not there it is
actually up there close to the coast of
Peru going around South America and we
need some automatically to identify this
and one thing we do know is we know that
we know when each message is received by
a satellite and we know where the
satellite is when it receives that
message and so we can look at the
position of the satellite which has -
usually has to be within about 3,000
kilometers of the of the of the boat to
receive a message to say roughly where
in the world it is but it turns out you
get a much more accurate estimate of
where that boat is if you take the
average position of satellites that
receive messages at the times they
receive the message over a given day so
what you want to do is you want to take
the average position of lat and long
over a day of a vessel and then the
average Latin long of the satellite
positions over a day and compare them so
you need to do latitude average Latin
long that's actually very tricky on on a
sphere and before spatial bigquery we
did something like this oh yeah so
there's the vessels actually up there
before a spatial bigquery did something
like this which is a lot of trigonometry
to turn the latitude longitude into XY
and Z and then average the XY and Z and
then turn them back into latitude and
longitude and took 32 lines of SQL and
with spatial bigquery we are now able to
do this in just the key calculation is
just one line where we turn SC centroid
AG and from the lot and longitude of all
the points for a given day and then are
able to get where that average location
is and this is a great so the one thing
I failed to say earlier is that all of
our AIS data is in bigquery and we use
it every day to use do almost every
analysis on what boats are doing and it
is been incredibly useful in in every
way of analysis and now we started using
it before spatial functions and there's
tons of cases where we figured out a
really hard way to do something and it
turns out this spatial big query can now
save us tons of time and effort and also
allow us to do things we weren't able to
simple things like just calculating the
distance between points is so much
easier now so here's one example so we
can identify these vessels more easily
that have their offsetting their
position but there's a bigger problem
which is that most fishing vessels don't
broadcast AIS we call this the dark
fleet and a lot of them aren't regulated
to carry it so they don't have to but
you can also imagine that if you are
want to engage in an elite in illegal
activity you are most likely not to
broadcast a is so we want to see these
boats how can we do it well one thing we
can do is use radar so as Tim talked
about there's a this is satellite called
Sentinel one from the European Space
Agency that has radar and the radar can
penetrate clouds and and see see bright
objects on water so this is a composite
image over several months if you look
between the United Kingdom and Europe
that's what you're looking there at the
English Channel you can see all those
dots which look that's the shipping
lanes and that's because metal objects
on water show up it's really bright in
radar and what we can do is we can look
at these scenes and we can count with
their likely vessels Sentinel one is the
satellite we're using and it covers all
the world's trestle service it doesn't
do the oceans but it does do all the
world's coastlines and most vessels
aren't close to shore so what we've done
is we say okay we're gonna process all
of the Sentinel one that overlaps with
the coastlines that's a few hundred
thousand images and over a petabyte of
data how do we process a petabyte of
radar imagery as I said we're a small
nonprofit we don't have tons of servers
sitting around but we do have Google
Earth engine like Google Earth engine
has two features that make it extremely
useful for us the first is that they
have it's a data catalog Onis they've
organized satellite imagery from tons of
the most useful freely available ice
island archives including say the entire
and they have the entire sentinel and
archive just sitting there and servers
so that we don't need to download and
pre-process it then built on top of that
there's a computational platform that
allows you to do analyses that scale
distributed across all of these all of
these all of these images so we can do
figure out a process for one image from
701 and then hit run and run it across
the whole globe here's a picture of what
the the viewer of it looks like there's
a nice Java Script there's a nice em
web-based JavaScript editor here at the
top gives you you can edit your code and
they share it it has an interactive map
that you can look at and work on and so
you can kind of play with it and see
what images look like I guess you're
analyzing them and then and then run
there's also there is also a Python API
and so we use the JavaScript tool to
kind of do the inspections write the
code and then we move it over and write
use the job use the Python API when we
want to put it into production to run
across to run across the whole globe
although you can also do some of that in
the JavaScript console so let's look at
one of these sent on one scenes let's
zoom in so this is what it looks like
the way you're looking on the Left
there's Italy on the right is Croatia
this is in the Adriatic Sea it's about
200 miles across is one scene the dark
area there is the footprint of the seam
that we have analyzed and all of those
dots are where our algorithm that we
used in Earth engine that is just
looking for bright spots on the water
says that there are probably vessels on
vessels now we want to compare this with
the AIS data which is also in bigquery
to say which of these dots are fishing
boats which of these are not fishing
boats and which these are vessels that
do not have a is to do that's a little
complicated because you can imagine that
satellite images taken at one time and
then you're a is positions aren't always
exactly at the point of the satellite
they may be a little bit before they may
be a little bit after and you need to do
some smart interpolation between those
two points to get the most likely
position of the vessel at the time of
the satellite to match it to these
detection 's also you want to clip it to
just this scene so you compare it to
only the scene you're looking at and I
don't have to process and compare all
the points outside so what we've done is
we've loaded all of this information
into spate into bigquery from the output
of Earth engine so we take the output of
Earth engine which gives us all of these
positions
and then also we take the outline of the
footprint so a polygon of the footprint
of that image we upload the footprint
that that footprint has a well-known
text into bigquery as well as all these
detections and then we can do a join on
the AIS data so we interpolate the SI
data at the AIS data and then do an st
contains four four points that are
within the footprint of the satellite at
the right position to identify which
vessels are most likely to match up with
which detections from radar and then
this seen lots of vessels use AAS so we
can match match it quite well and so the
red dots there are things that we think
are fishing vessels the the turquoise
ones are ones that are non fishing
vessels and the gray ones are ones that
we are not matched there could be
objects in the water we're identifying
those another way but a lot of them are
vessels that do not broadcast AIS zoom
out to the entire Adriatic Sea you can
see Italy's on the left there and to the
right is the former Yugoslavian
countries and then in the south is
Greece and this is all detections over
one year in this area and you can see
the shipping lanes you can see some
fishing activity and we now are able to
put all this into bigquery and match it
at scale to identify which of these we
think are non fishing vessels which of
these are fishing vessels and which of
these are not matched if you look on the
right on the the East Coast they're on
the east side of the the sea close to
what is albania you see a bunch of grey
activity albania does not require its
fleet to carry a is so it that could be
the fishing fleet and we've done one
more thing here which is we have trained
a model to identify based solely on
where an object is in the ocean using
features such as the the the bathymetry
the slope of the bathymetry the whether
or not it's close to a shipping lane the
distance from shore all these features
which we actually generated with joins
and bigquery we use those features on
each observation and they're able to
make a guess about whether it's a
fishing boat or a non fishing vessel
I've also added in the bottom here a
dotted line here that that yellow dotted
line
which is the area of a proposed marine
protected area okay sorry I've so
retained a model and we're able to guess
with some confidence you know so
probabilistically that those red dots
are likely fishing vessels so you can
see that's that's a dark fleet of
fishing vessels there on the on the
right side they're most that are not
broadcasting why does this matter well
the yellow dotted line there is a marine
protected area that's been proposed in
the southern Adriatic and so we had a
non-profit in Europe come to us and say
do you you know can you tell us what
fishing activity is happening within
this proposed area because we want to
talk with the fishing industry and have
negotiations about where this marine
protected area will be how much fishing
will be affected by it and we don't know
how much fishing is there so we're able
to use this method to then now let's
zoom into that that area and there's a
bunch of fishing on the on the west side
on the left you can't see because it's
underneath the turquoise dots and let's
just look at the fishing and zoom in and
we're able to say that this is this is
the fishing activity over 2017 of
vessels within that proposed area which
is now extremely useful for having those
discussions about about where where to
site this marine protected area so again
we're trying to create transparency in
the world's fishing industry use Mille
to use spatial bigquery has been a huge
assist to us because as we spend so much
of our time in bigquery analyzing data
processing things and these functions
have allowed us to really get another
few steps forward and creating
transparency in fishing and the reason
we want to create transparency and
fishing is because we want more places
like this this is a real picture taken
by one of our research partners on teams
and reeks ala of National Geographic
Christine sees that shows off a marine
protected area that is incredible
abundance of sharks and our goal is to
protect you know have as many places
like this as we can in the world and one
of the ways we can do that is to
luminate the world's dark fleets which
we think will help end illegal
unreported and unregulated fishing by
industrial fishing vessels thank you
very much and now I'm gonna hand it off
to Moshe who is the chief big
query engineer I do have to say I've
been doing bigquery now for the last
three and a half years and I did take a
selfie with him earlier because I was
very excited to meet the man behind what
we've been using it at global fishing
watch I think you David
so it's been really fascinating for me
to listen to both of those talks from
Jim and David and see how things that we
built into product into bigquery how
they used in real world for such great
causes
so my portion of the work is going to be
about I will tell you how bigquery was
able to achieve all those to be able to
power those applications and to be able
to do those special analysis at such a
big scale so I'm going to talk about
every single detail and every single
algorithm maybe maybe not every single
one but hopefully the most important
ones and explain how it works so one
little warning there will be a little
bit of math in this presentation but
nothing too hard nothing like high
schools colors come out G of s ok so
let's start one of the great things
about welcome can Google is that we have
volt expert on about every single
subject and of course Google has been
doing you know geography Gillian quick
jog Rafi date and location data for very
very long time have products like Google
Maps and Google Earth engine and Google
searches obviously location event and
the oeid and you know it's really easier
to find products which don't use
locations so there is a lot of expertise
inside Google and all those products
sell it'll be different but at the heart
of all of them and the co of them is
this amazing low level library called as
to geography like geometry library which
deals with low very low level details
which also pinky details you know how
you do all the economically and how you
do it on a surface of the earth so
earlier what we were building cost
engine con the shoulders of giants and
you know were using you know this
technology started
thousand five fifteen years in making
kids very much a bust battle-tested and
by the way it's open source so it's not
just google who uses it there are many
other companies probably the other most
well-known one is Pokemon gone I don't
know if anybody is still playing but it
has something that we felt really good
about and remember when I said we have
all the world experts so the guy behind
this library Eric rich his legend when
he was PhD student he worked on computer
graphic and his thesis was on radiation
and that Sal gave me still used in
pretty much every rotation software
today she actually got Oscars for it
now if you watched monsters incorporated
so that's his work anyway he just
happens to work out of Seattle same
building same floor as be creative is so
when what can be clear joyous and we had
some pretty question all I had to do is
stand up walk 20 meters say hey now how
would you always polygons caution can
see Meridian near poles and here's how
do that ok so we will be going now into
the internals of s2 and stay with me
I'll explain later how we use it and
said Bikram tries it useful and tries it
guide ok
so we start with our first assumption
that Earth is around and you know we're
all grown-ups here well of course not
that this is not tool and I I don't mean
the devote is flat but it's not actually
a sphere right it's an ellipsoid but you
know spheres easier to work with and
Anna's and I think that all the
topological property of ellipsoid
appreciat on a sphere only distances
become different so we can compensate
for it later
ok so what starts in quiz round off but
first think we do you know it's hard to
index on a sphere so first think don't
say well what if also is actually cube
all right so with all Cuba on the earth
and we project every single point to the
faces of cube the six of them and why is
it simpler because the faces of the cube
actually flat and
on a flat surface we can do all their it
metrics and you know all the
calculations much much easier okay so
how you actually project from a sphere
to a cube Oh for single point is very
easy right the formulas table but then
what happens is when you project an air
if it's closer to a quarter right in the
middle it will be smaller if you go
Knossos it becomes a bigger impaction
distortion becomes as big as five times
began this is not good if we want to do
precise indexing so we have to do some
adjustment yeah
we'll have to do some adjustments again
it becomes little bit tricky to do exact
adjustments we need to do arctangent and
that's by the way the method was
referring to that's end of the math
which is very expensive so what s2 came
up with really nice quadratic
approximation which is almost a space
sizes TIG anomaly and almost as fast as
a linear one okay so now we have a
method of projection points and guess
into the face of the cube so let's take
one of the faces of the cube right there
are six of them so this is one and you
see already projected see how it flat it
is because it's on a cube so now in
order to index it we're going to build
the team and usually in computer science
when people talk about T's they talk
about binary t's but since it's
two-dimensional now we built what's
called karate so we take the whole face
and divide it into four squares okay and
then take each one of those squares and
divide it again into first class and we
do it again and again and again actually
we do it 30 times so we have 30 levels
in our tape and each one of those
squares is called cube so we have to in
power of 30 by 2 in power of 32 in power
of 60 different cells if you look at the
cell the lowest level at the level 30
it's about one square centimeter so we
have 6 faces it nicely fits into 64-bit
integer so just think about it I'm
working Keanu same
and each my step I'm having hand eight
of those cells and each one of them has
unique integer associated with it I
think it's great so we're using those
integers as our indexes now to get good
spatial indexing by the way you know
I've often talked about how bigquery you
know it's everything to scan and there
are no indexes so this of course
simplification of course behind this
since it uses all kinds of takes ok just
not visible to the user which is a great
thing for the user because you don't
have to worry about it what do it for
you so the next thing we need to do is
to figure out how to connect all those
cells together at its two-dimensional
and we build what is called spell
space-filling curve and for your skill
burger here and nice property of this
curve is points which are close together
in a halo volt usually not always but
most of the time and tab being close to
each other
on this curve okay for example you know
those two cells are close to each other
they will be right next to each other of
course there are exceptions and so this
is too far cannot jump and show you a
couple of points which are closing the a
level button that being fired on Hilbert
curve but this is relatively rare okay
so to recap we talked around us Putin
tend to cube project that put Hilbert
often you may wonder like what does this
has to do anything with big gray and dry
ass and you know how am I going to use
it so now I will walk you through a
luxurious
okay well looking at polygons and people
from New York will immediately identify
this polygon this is of course
Metropolitan Museum of Arts in okay so
the polygon is a little bit complex
they're like dozen edges and whatnot and
let's say what we wanted to do also have
a lot of points and we want to find out
which ones inside the museum and which
one outside so to do it exactly it's
actually can potentially expensive
think if for what to check it for every
point so this is where we start using
our indexes
so what we do first is we try to find a
minimal sell out of those you know
illogical cells which completely covers
all polygons ok so here's one and it
also covers some area which is not in
the museum in fact more than half of it
so say ok well we don't have to use
single integer right we can use
those are 4 cells so it becomes a little
better we can use 8 cells so can use 16
cells so would be clearly does every
time you have geography object can be
query it automatically picks the most
optimal covering over those cell ideas
and remember each one is just an integer
and it does it favor charge right you're
not paying anything for it we do it for
you
you don't paint for stores you're not
paying for computations it's all
transparent ok so there is a trade-off
of course we don't want to use too many
indexes but also don't want to use too
few so it depends on the shape depends
on how many points you have is I want to
say we use machine learning for that but
you know we'll use algorithms for that
so we build it so the next step is now
have all those points and you need to
figure out which are inside and which
ones outside and now we have this very
very fast algorithm each point has its
own as cell as to cell and our object
has its own cell covering so all we need
to do is to compare integers to quickly
figure out which points have absolutely
no chance of being inside polygons and
if you think about them if you have
millions of them we can you know pull
out a lot of them very very quickly now
of course there will be some false
positive again I I cannot show and laser
doesn't work here the couple of points
which inside cover outside of museum
we'll have to check them separately but
hopefully this number is small so be
clear actually does much more than that
it also compute the covering of every
chart of data and you know if you have
points somewhere in Seattle San
Francisco
they have no business would have no
business chicken you know if they in New
York so we can very quickly prune out
all of those partitions and again all of
that happens completely automatically
but for those algorithms to be effective
we also want to make sure that points
which have physically close together
they also end up close to get inside
date of declare table and this is where
the hilbert curve that we talked about
will be useful so you know how the query
has clustering which usually only works
with integers and stems well we can also
do clustering by geography not today but
very soon we will release it so on I'm
pronouncing this Oh
nobody formality it doesn't matter okay
I'm pronouncing that very soon you will
be able to take your table with drug
affinity and just C cluster bait and you
are going to get you know very you know
you will get special class tank and your
performance is going be great and as we
saw in those applications which analyze
the entire vault it's already great it
will become even greater okay so to wake
up today we looked a little bit into how
big their internals look and to look at
a couple of fairly amazing applications
that people built on top of it and you
can find on those links more info about
it and we're looking forward to your
building your application thank you
[Applause]
[Music]